let's step back a little bit and look at
Mars and lakes on Mars just going back
to your PhD and before and maybe today
what do we understand about life on Mars
what do we understand about Lakes on
Mars is there water on Mars what do we
understand about the conditions from
four billion years ago on Mars well
we've gone a long way remember from from
the Viking where we had no resolution
well we'll had a little bit more
resolution with than with Mariners what
did you think at that time sorry to
interrupt it was just take us back to
that mindset it was really the
exploration like the your first look
at a planet you have to remember that
the first mission that successfully
snapped some pictures of Martha was
Mariner for
and then everybody at that time was
still under the spell of you know it's
Wells and and the idea that Mars looked
with telescope so similar to the Earth
polar caps we could see them with a
telescope and we knew it had season the
actual tilt is pretty much the same as
the one for Earth so when Mariner 4 left
everybody pre not everybody but a lot of
people thought that we would see the
crystal cities and domes and stuff that
another civilization might have evolved
in parallel to us in the solar system
and of course when the first images came
back and Mars looked with that kind of
resolution it I had uh like the Moon it
was a huge disappointment then Mariner 9
came
and that changed everything there is
there was a little bit of drama because
Mars started the one of the biggest
storm it ever experienced and so for
three months we had an orbiters circling
around Mars and not seeing anything
but then when the dust cleared all of a
sudden we started discovering volcanoes
valleys ancient channels Dune Fields
polar caps and see what I'm talking to
you I don't need to invent any words
to describe Mars
and although the myth of
extraterrestrial civilization on Mars
was gone all of a sudden
the imagination of the scientists
started to pick up because right away we
were seeing something that was familiar
that we could describe so right away
Viking would put on The Fast Track and
the idea was so Mars looks so much like
Earth could have been although it's arid
and there is little atmosphere Etc
could there be life and of course behind
this at the time there were people like
a Klein and Sagan called Sagan uh just
you know uh thinking about how can we
test the idea of biology of Life on Mars
so this is what Viking did but of course
at the time when the two lenders arrived
on Mars
we didn't have the context of the
geology of the environment we didn't
have much data at all so the data that
Viking
send back was very confusing some people
still think today that we discovered
Life on Mars at the time because some of
the experiment turned out to show a
strange signal but most of the community
think that it can be explained by a
chemical reaction that we see today so
it was so confusing that NASA decided to
say okay if we want to be serious about
looking for Life on Mars we have to
understand the environment because life
and environment co-evolve
so as cause or effect a planet is going
to give you the physical chemical
environment for life to happen these are
the boundaries but once life is here
it's going to change everything one of
the biggest impact of life was to inject
oxygen into the atmosphere of the earth
three two billion years ago and that
changed everything including our
signature in space
so there is this coevolution so if you
want to understand one you have to
remove the other from the equation this
kind of a two unknown equation so even
though oxygen changes our signature
today
what if all life on Earth died and now
we fast forward a billion years
what would be the traces left it so the
question I'm trying to ask is
if life had existed on Mars what would
be the signs we would look for that's a
very good question the thing is that if
you draw the parallel with Earth it took
82 percent of Earth's history
geological history to go from very
simple life microbial life to complexity
and when I'm saying complexity I'm not
even talking about us I'm talking about
animals so Marcy smaller lost its
magnetic field very fast and lost his
atmosphere is very fast
life also
appeared on Earth very fast so the
condition being quite similar at that
time between the Earth and Mars it's
assumed for a moment that life appeared
on Mars it would have been Simple Life
when conditions started to degrade which
was less than a billion year after the
planet had formed so everything at the
surface
would have disappeared except maybe for
morphological traces of the interaction
between life and its environment so on
Earth the best example are what we call
stromatolites these are rock formation
that are built by microbes so we know
that we we know how to recognize them
you could have chemical traces as well
there is some interesting question marks
right now about carbon Isotopes at
Crater because we found an abundance of
C12 which normally is used by life on
Earth but it can produce be produced by
other things so it's not that it's a
real bio signature in itself but it's
intriguing we have now the C12 and we
have methane but uh going back it's a
Time on Mars 3.5 billion years ago where
you have lots of distractions where you
have lots of impact cratering Etc so but
we still have very old rocks that are
that survive from that time so these are
good uh good places that's why we're
sending the Rovers in those places
ancient lakes and impact craters and and
places where you have very old rocks So
when you say ancient lakes and impact
craters the simple question so impact
Creator is a Creator created by a giant
rock hitting the planet and yes a big
rock that can be metal or rock or it can
be a comet as well mostly eyes so is
that good for life or bad for life
it's actually both
um interestingly enough the building
blocks of life the bricks the stuff we
are made of carbon hydrogen oxygen and
nitrogen and phosphorus they were
included
on our planet they were built in just
because our planet is made of this kind
of rocks asteroids and comets coming
together by what we call a Christian so
they were built in when an asteroid
comes there is a lot of Destruction
going on but at the same time those
rocks they bring with them those bricks
of life and they create lots of energy
and if the environment around is
favorable you might possibly be have
some sitting going on that's one of the
aspect of what we call panspermia which
is the fact that comets and asteroid
have the building blocks of life and
better than them and that given
favorable condition they might be able
to see planets this is a theory